hey guys today i'm going to show you how
to change your windows vista log on
screen
so what you're going to do is open up
your web browser and you will copy
and paste this link
it's in the description and i will
leave you to click it uh it's
howtogeek.com
and you get 16 tweaks to this to look
and feel and this is called
customize your boot vista logon screen
um
so i'm going to click this right here
and what i want to do is
go to download
logon studio from star doc it's free
click on it
you'll get it uh the log on the
stardock.com website logon studio
download link
you can either download it from cnet
downloads or
oh this is from for xp and this is for
vista
download it if you have vista from this
link and it's 3.12 megs here's a you
know
it's really simple program so i'll hit
download now
and any second it will come up here we
go i hit open
and now it's beginning
now it begins to download log on
studio vista so i'll come back when this
is done all right guys it's done and
it's going to come up uh well first of
all you can close your downloads window
and now you can't hit the run button
cmd comes up i'm going to allow this
program to run
first of all it says welcome to the
setup program it should be relatively
simple i'll hit next next next and
installing and we're done so i'm going
to launch and finish
this should exit out
exit this and it's launched also they
were kind enough to give me a
sweet little icon on my desktop now you
can download more uh
uh desktops this is for this is the
windows vista default logon screen you
can upload some create one download more
i want to click that it'll open up your
internet browser and you can go and
search for ones that other people have
uploaded
so before you even go into and upload
yours
50 downloads today i'm going to click on
that and i'm going to show you what it's
like to download it so here's the
download link it'll tell you it's only
two megs
um
i hit download and
let's see if it automatically does it or
i have to click it again
all right i'll click it
here it is open
it's approximately two megs as they
promised
so actually i'll just not pause it and
wait until this one's done
actually no i'll pause this one i'll
come back in a sec
all right and here it is
it says do you want to open the file of
course i do
and bam
now it's in vista logon studio i didn't
even have to import into the program
files or anything so i'll minimize this
exit my web browser
clear my downloads exit that so now
we're just focusing on logon studio for
vista
um
this is it
log on studio for vista
you can load some in
some you can delete some
um basically all you have to do is
click it hit
apply and there it is
i will swipe my finger to unlock i don't
know if you can see that
but
it locked basically locked my computer
and showed me what it would be
so
that is what it is
um i'll
try to give you an image now i don't
know if i can do that
but um
it works it has this image in the
background and it has you know your
little
um
your little avatar for whatever you are
this is both when you lock your computer
and when you shut down your computer i
really like this so i'm going to just
hit save
it's asking me where do i want to save
the package um
i'll say log on screen
and exit
so i put it in the my documents folder
which is interesting i have a ton in
here
and i double click on it and it's saying
oh it's going to bring up the okay i
don't have to do that then it's just a
shortcut
i'm going to delete it
yes please
exit cool little logo they made
so whenever i want to search for it i'll
just type log on
and what do you know log on screen is
right there
so there you have it guys that is how
you change
i'll post a link in the description for
how to get this i really like it i've
been using it for about a week
i just uninstalled it so i can show you
guys how to install it and this is how
you change your background in uh your
logon screen in windows vista enjoy guys
subscribe peace
you